foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
two one two one two one two
one two ladies and Gentlemen people of
the internet welcome back
welcome back to another Tuesday edition
of retro
live
[Music]
oh man oh we did a
morning stream over on Twitch today went
for about six hours with gameplay
several of you already in the chat here
I know we're hanging out for that one as
well
appreciate you guys being there
had a lot of fun starting our dark arts
playthrough which will be coming to
YouTube by the way
that one I'm gonna carry over
because right now like I played a lot of
the game offline in my first playthrough
didn't even stream a lot of it on Twitch
as far as like The Story Goes then once
I beat it
or even we did some story stuff over on
Twitch and and some on YouTube as well
you can go on the lives and find some of
our previous streams where we've
streamed some gameplay
but most of the streams that we did were
me collecting finishing up side quests
all that sort of thing
pretty sure I beat the game off stream
yeah I definitely don't remember doing
like the final boss or anything on
Stream So now this time it's like okay
first playthrough we were good
Gryffindor right what we wanted to be
no unforgivable curses at all we didn't
learn any of them then this playthrough
we're going dark arts
so we got sorted into Slytherin today
named ourselves Lord retro Mort
and so that one will definitely be
coming over to YouTube I'm just gonna
condense them down so they're not so
like today we went over six hours so
it's not gonna be that long we're gonna
cut it cut and edit those down a bit I
was recording my footage as well so
it'll be nice high quality for you guys
but hope you all are doing well tonight
on this Tuesday evening here we'll be
chatting all things Hogwarts Legacy in
terms of
news around the game no Major Spoilers I
mean we may discuss some gameplay things
here and there
but uh yeah so let's check in with the
chat over here see who we got I see Jake
was the first one here sorry we were a
little bit uh later than usual man doing
these two a day streams it's rough
it's rough like I basically have enough
time to we enter the stream I don't know
5 30 or so my time so I have enough time
to get dinner be with the wife and kids
for a little bit get them in bed
and it's like oh it's time to get ready
for the stream again
so we may eventually tweak some times or
something I don't know maybe maybe we
can like
if I started on Twitch earlier then
maybe we could lead into an earlier
YouTube stream maybe like a 5 p.m
YouTube stream or 4 P.M YouTube stream
something like that
because dude
having them this late it's getting tough
to keep up
but you guys keep showing up man you
keep showing up and so we're gonna keep
doing it and as you guys know how the
way the show always goes I mean I have a
loose kind of outline of topics we'll
hit all the latest news and things of
course the delay is going to be the big
one some other things that I've found in
terms of uh the Goblins if you guys
follow me on or not Goblins the Gnomes
if you all follow me on Twitter you've
already seen me talking about this one
so we'll chat about that some too
because I think that is super
interesting and then as I was getting
ready to go live for tonight I thought
you know what we should do next week
unless there's just some major major
news
next week I might have it just be like a
full-on review
spoiler cast kind of stream where I just
talk about everything
like my full impressions of the game
and eventually I might post a video
about that too but I feel like it might
be fun just to do sort of an off the
cuff
just giving you guys my my reactions and
then hearing from you in real time your
reactions to the game because I've
I mean obviously I love the game so it's
not like my opinion has changed largely
but it is it is interesting to see
like when you're how you feel when
you're five hours in when you're 15
hours in when you're 80 hours in when
you're 80 hours in starting a second
playthrough like we did today
so I thought that might be fun but uh we
got Jake we got Patrick zutara babe
how's it going noob in the house noob
are you not twitch person Noob I haven't
seen noob in a while
how's it been going new if you staying
busy
because we get the nice
pop of the top
let's see
l-i-o-r leor how's it going welcome in
soundtrack oh you're on PS4 dude
so you got a little bit longer of a
weight I definitely I definitely get the
frustration
for sure
Jenny is here as well welcome in Jenny
Nico the mods are probably like okay
retro these two Edition these two a days
we got we gotta do something about this
we gotta do something about this we
can't be having like a 12 hour stream
day
[Music]
Mr rinyart still watching from work so
slow oh you're still at work is it
trickling by
yeah moose uh welcome in welcome in I
think we answered the spoiler question
there uh j-a-s-cr 2010
how's it going dude welcome in welcome
in
and then let's see just catch you
watching your YouTube videos hey thank
you appreciate it lior
appreciate it we just posted a new one
today if you guys haven't seen yet
which the response in the video has been
really really solid but the thumbnail is
not doing well so I might have to change
that thumbnail after tonight people are
not clicking that one as high
as they usually do so we gotta edit that
thumbnail make it a slightly different
one
I thought man I thought like putting a
little photo mode thing on there I
thought people would be like oh photo
mode yes I want photo mode and Hogwarts
Legacy and then
but no it's not doing well
not doing well so we're gonna tweak that
one a bit tonight
let's see then we had Amy in the house
ether late a we were late getting
started but it's all good a wizard
and witch will throw in Wizard and
witches are never late
precisely when we mean to
then we had Curtis Mr cold just with a
random Molly Weasley what was that what
was that about Mr cold Molly Weasley
Amy welcome in Amy then we had Ryan
how's it going Ryan Gina
Amy wait a different Amy no no same Amy
same Amy
skull how's it going skull
and then we had marvolo Ravenclaw hey I
saw you in the comments today marvolo
thank you for being here tonight
thank you for being here we got Evie in
the chat there's Lauren D I recognize
Lauren's name from the chat
who else here who else we got JP raven
fire
and then we already said Jenny and then
EV
store how's it going mu store
a fellow Dark Lord with the mort name I
know right
we were we were figuring out today retro
Mort
it's like you know how Voldemort means
flight from death
this would just be retro death
retro death
Daniel Peterson welcome in I think so
Daniel I do they're saying no they're
saying uh
well they're not saying no but they're
saying no current plans and with the
delay
that'd really be very bad Optics if
they're like oh yeah we're working on
DLC it's coming out at this point yeah
wouldn't look good would not look good
so
I think for sure that with this game the
way this game's selling I'd be shocked
I'd be incredibly incredibly shocked if
we don't get multiple DLCs
Fallen how's it going it was a quick
break it was a quick break
[Music]
magic awaken question mark Pablo I'm not
sure what your question is I don't I
still don't think it's out in the U.S
maybe at some point
babe you like the idea of a full spoiler
stream oh man I've been waiting dude
I've been telling James I'm like James
expect it'll go for those of you don't
know I think he's actually live on
Twitch right now playing let me see if
he's still alive
he was still alive when I went on
yeah he's still alive I think he was
trying to beat the game tonight let's
see where he's at
oh
he's at the mission I'm not gonna pull
it up because I don't want to spoil
anybody who hasn't played but you know
what you know that late game mission
that yeah yeah yeah yeah you know the
one you know the one he's at that
mission
he's at that mission
but yeah Miranda's still not finished
last I heard Ben still not finished with
the story
uh let's see
Lynette did finish the story I was
misunderstood misinformed I guess I
thought Lynette still wasn't done either
but I got to tell him I was like guys
you got to get done
in a joking way you know I just want to
talk to them about it
I want to talk to them about the game I
want to just like full spoiler you know
go crazy talking about all the little
details and stuff that we found
so looking forward to finally getting to
discuss with people
all right that music is just a wee bit
loud and I have it already really low
I mean I barely have it
I think it's just this song
Craig welcome in Craig
uh you don't use twitch much new gotcha
gotcha we have our standard
Cherry Coke Zero tonight Fallen
Noob hey you don't like you don't use
twitch much we've gotta hydrate command
not a hydrate command there are these
Channel points on Twitch that
it's just like a fun little engagement
interactive kind of thing and you earn
them just by hanging out in the chat
following subscribing earns you more so
and one of them you can redeem hydrate
so it's like reminding me to
take a sip of water or Coke Zero
whatever we're drinking at the time
oh what delay are we talking about the
uh so Hogwarts Legacy was delayed this
week for
lashed in systems so it was scheduled to
come out in April
for both PS4 and Xbox One and now
they've pushed it back just a little
it's like a month and a day I think they
pushed it back to May
and then there's still which
this is the next question right what
does that mean for the switch version
what does that mean for the switch
version
I don't know man
I still say the switch is a cloud
version I do
I still say it is
Maybe not maybe not but I mean my
goodness how low res are they gonna have
to turn that game to get it to run on a
switch
hello
Nico with the seven months how's it
going Nico welcome in thank you for
being a member here for seven months I
still can't believe it's only been seven
months that's crazy to me
feels like we've been doing this for so
much longer
with a lot of Irregulars here
Lord retro Mort will return that's right
tomorrow
we will be back live on Twitch again for
more
Lord retro Mort gameplay as a Slytherin
dude hopefully we'll be able to get into
some more of the fun stuff I mean the
beginning is great but it's
playing it through the second time I had
totally forgotten is no Major Spoilers
but I totally forgotten how many
there's just so much reading at the
beginning there's a lot of dialogue
you're going back and forth talking to a
lot of people which there's a lot of
systems you know that they had to set up
in the world for the first time plus
where I'm playing it on stream I'm like
I'm not skipping through things because
we're gonna um post it on YouTube as
well for people who want to see the
whole thing right but
yeah man having to watch all the cut
scenes and all the dialogue again
that part's been a little weird but I
think tomorrow we should start to get
into some more of the the good parts
I think so let's see Pablo is there a
fair chance that awaken is coming I mean
so your guess is as good as mine
last year there was a moment where they
said hey it's coming out soon in the U.S
and UK and then it never did
and then I think when was it guys toward
the end of last year toward the end of
is that when they finally said hey magic
awakened
it's coming next year
but it was really broad it was really
really Broad
batch Quest gaming welcome in how's it
going
[Music]
oh it just did the thing it just did the
thing where the comments
Fly Away
all right there's fetch Quest
Christopher welcome in Christopher good
to have you here
that's Quest you beat the game today
nice uh now you gotta go for that 100 my
100 is bugged right now guys it's so sad
it's so sad it's bugged Darren welcome
in Darren how's it going
Star Wars or Harry Potter Fallen do you
know where you're at
Fallen do you know
do you know which stream you're in right
now
[Music]
do you know do you know
Harry Potter all the way for me I mean I
enjoy Star Wars like fine but it is
it's just like something I enjoy I I am
not
I'm not even like a fanboy of Star Wars
I would say I just like I've seen the
movies and that's that's it like I
haven't read the books I've played a few
of the games
Harry Potter man I'm I'm like all in on
the Wizarding World all in pretty much
everything that's ever been made
involving the Wizarding World
aside from cursed child uh I've just
been like all in on it
you're just newbie dad
you store if you got the Platinum soon
oh you hope I get the Platinum soon
well I still me store I still have to do
the other I still have to get on all the
uh
I have to get to that one point on all
the accounts you know
I have to get to the map room with each
house
yeah after that I'm
I'm not worried about it I'm sure
they'll they'll they'll patch it
I'm sure they will patch it at some
point I don't think I could do your
trick that you were talking about
earlier because I don't have anything
else left to collect
so even if I deleted it and installed it
from the original version
without that first patch I mean maybe it
would just pop automatically do you see
what I'm saying like I don't have
anything to go and
unlock to sort of trigger the
there you go now you're getting
I don't know but if they don't patch it
soon
I'm definitely open to trying things
definitely open
quidditch DLC I don't think so
I don't think so dlc's downloadable
content soundtrack so
I mean that's a very broad way but
usually when people talk DLC they mean
updates to the game in the form of like
big expansions
so things that are added to the game
after its launch
for an additional price
so
and I think you know we don't know
because they haven't announced anything
officially they've said there are no
current plans
but I think for Hogwarts Legacy a lot of
people are hoping for like some
additional mini games and a DLC
story is the biggest thing for me like I
want more story I want more
if we if we could go Pie in the Sky you
know I want more enemy types I want more
locations like oh that'd be awesome
yeah if you look at uh like like The
Witcher is a good example of some DLC
that was done very very well so they had
the main game The Witcher 3 and then
there was a DLC called blood and wine
and then there was additional DLC I
can't think of the name of it right now
but yeah you could just look those up
Skyrim is another big one but a lot of
games do DLC these days
Witchblade 59 welcome in
Professor Baxter how's it going Baxter
good to see you
Anson edits please die playing slow
[Music]
so sad Brian I'm sorry dude I know I
know
just when we were I mean about a month
out right it was about a month
yeah it's about a month away that it was
supposed to launch on last gen PS4 and
Xbox One
[Music]
foreign
you still not finished Jake hey take
your time dude take your time are they
like mini I mean they could be anything
soundtrack they could DLC like The
Witcher I see I use is a good example
because it is like a full
just like completely additional story
stories really
but it's different for different games
you know I mean deal technically DLC in
the just the very loose sense of the
word technically the dark arts cosmetic
set is downloadable content right
because it's some it's something that if
you purchase the standard version you
can buy it as an add-on so that's like
downloadable content it's a very small
example it could be as simple as
something like a few Cosmetics or it
could be full-on story it could be
completely different modes
you look at a game like ghost of
tsushima a single player game a great
single player game but then their DLC
one of their first first big DLCs was a
completely new mode that was multiplayer
the DLC I mean these days
it's it can mean so many different
things
use the mod to bring Sebastian to that
mission it was so fun I saw the mod
where
oh I saw a video of somebody where it's
like you can take companions anywhere
crazy that that that was already like
kind of built into the game
and it just needed to be unlocked I'm
sure there are some things that would
break if you took them to certain places
but
Lynette is 100 and do it yeah yeah so I
think that's where I got confused JP I
thought she hadn't beat the story at all
41 hours Jenny but about 46 on the
challenges oh my goodness
Hufflepuff next in Gryffindor for my
Volo
[Music]
took you over 70 hours to 100 yeah yeah
take your time take your time enjoy it
there's so much to enjoy
100 on challenges 149 out of 150 on
Field Guide ether yes yes I'm in the
same spot
we were looking for it today right when
we started our stream over on Twitch I
was just showing people like hey look I
can't get this last one and I've pulled
up guides and I've checked every single
one mine's in the belts out or the uh
yeah the Bell Tower
I think
but but I still have if you go to the
collections page I have all of those
done
like I have all of the revelio pages
there complete
so I don't know if I got it and it just
didn't count it or
if it just never showed up in the world
and I wasn't able to get it I'm not sure
just join twitch hard finding people to
watch most the time well Professor
Baxter make sure you follow twitch.tv
retro raconteur and then anytime I'm
online you'll see me over there
you will see me over in the left hand
side
[Music]
oh yeah JP we've been streaming on on
there every I've been trying to do
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday we usually
start around 10 a.m eastern time around
10 10 30 and then go for about six seven
hours today we went for about six and a
half we did do a Friday night stream a
while back too but yeah we've been doing
a lot of twitch streams
as well as we make our way through the
game so we we've 100 we're done but we
just now we gotta get that bug to fix
and then we also have to get the the
trophies for the other houses yeah
[Music]
foreign
to avoid watching too much uh yeah I
could see that
I can see that
all roads lead to hogsmeade indeed
oh my gosh yeah I'm I'm way behind oh
wait hold on we're not that far behind
we're not that far behind
mission after the house exclusives gave
you a little trouble while we're trying
to navigate it
after the house exclusives
that one's not ringing a bell right away
to me played the whole game on hard mode
let's go I'm doing that for my second
run I wish I had done it on my first
I wish I'd done it on my first hard mode
felt too easy especially since I'm doing
uh I'm gonna do dark arts on this one so
like one side fully upgraded everything
because I turned it to Hard Mode I don't
know when I was
on my first playthrough I turned it up
to hard mode but I was a pretty good
ways in I think we'd already beaten the
story and I was just doing side quests
and stuff and I was like okay I'm just
gonna turn it up and see what it's like
and at that point I was already so
powerful that
like yeah I should have done this
earlier
should have done this earlier
yeah that's why I want a new game plus
so bad in our video today if you guys
haven't seen it that was my number one
thing I'd love to see the Mad Hogwarts
Legacy is a new game plus mode
give us some reasons to go back
Pete how's it going welcome in good to
see you here
skull finished a few days ago use your
Wizarding World data first playthrough
nice yeah I'm Gryffindor too
Jay Rossi welcome in welcome in
you completed it nice dude I knew you'd
love it man I knew you'd love it
Dustin what's up Dustin I know yeah no
current plans
the way this game is selling
or sure
change the seasons I like that idea too
no because I do I don't that's one that
you I feel like you kind of have to
suspend
like okay we're officially playing a
game now we're not like immersed in the
world anymore
or I guess I don't know how would they
do it like make it like it's resets like
you're back then and students could I
don't know
but I do I do want the option because I
I miss not being able to see some of
those other Seasons because they just
look so great
they look so great anyone else thinking
like sneaking up on camps hiding casting
Imperials starting in the inner Camp War
randomly throwing objects as they fight
each other I haven't done that yet
either because I don't have the
unforgivables but this playthrough
this playthrough I will have a chance to
do just that
just that
oh me source so you think if I just
install the game I won't have to do
anything and it'll just if I uninstall
reinstall you think it'll just pop right
away
I might try it
I might try it Alden welcome in Alden
how's it going
do a room of requirement tour yours is
so boring
I haven't put a lot of time into the
room of requirement I'll tell you I
definitely need to
but it's just like once you hit the
point of it doing everything you need
then
it's like why do I need to go back here
but I have I have heard I haven't looked
at them myself yet but I have heard of
people making some truly truly elaborate
that might be a fun idea for a YouTube
stream one week
is like the whole stream we could just
be hanging out in the room of
requirement and I can be making my
because I have all the conjurations now
on my first my main playthrough I have
all the conjuration so we could make
anything in the game we should be able
to make
counter but yeah there's definitely a
bug definitely something going on with
that one
[Music]
you beat it four times already Caleb oh
my goodness
that is crazy
Destiny miss all the streams
the Friday night stream was the only one
you catch other than the Tuesday nights
yeah I can't win Dustin I can't win on
the top the stream times
our folks over in the UK they can't make
the night ones and then the day ones
there's you know people who are working
during the day can't make those so we'll
just you know keep trying to offer a
variety but I will say like my vods stay
up on Twitch for 60 days I think 60.
yeah so I know it's not the same not
watching it live but they are still up
there if you guys want to go back and
and with the playthrough that we started
today
I'm recording my gameplay so I'm going
to be able to bring that over to YouTube
so you guys can look for that in like
let's play form here on YouTube and
I don't know however I'd say by the end
of the week hopefully by this weekend I
can get that one posted it's just a
matter of editing it down that one will
actually today's will probably end up
being two videos because we have over
six hours of of stream
probably about five and a half of actual
gameplay then we split it into the
middle that's you know two hours and two
and a half hours on each one right
around there and then edit them down
further I think we can get them both to
under two hours so
I don't know I'll just have to see where
like a logical breaking point is but
yeah we're bringing those over to
YouTube on on let's plays
you found out about the ancient magic
hot spots after beating the game what
they're on them they're marked on the
map
want more story and the ability to sell
more than clothing gear hey I'm with EJ
Rossi more story would be awesome
Noob with the four months Noob thank you
so much for continuing to be a member
here appreciate it just started another
play on PC hopefully if the mod works I
get fiend fire confundo obliviates
Stupify as slottables what house do I
pick
let him know chat what do you think Go
Ninja Go welcome in how's it going good
to see you
great Aurelius just found out how to get
into all the common rooms what is that
um
is that on PC or something with a mod
is that with a mod
what are you talking about sir
Amy do I have any advice let's see hold
on what for
you just got stuck
after going to get the wand after
completing all the keepers trials
uh where are you like are you at
ollivanders
or actually trying to get out somewhere
got the wand after getting below the
shore but I am stuck
I don't know if you mean like physically
stuck or something else
like if it literally won't let your
character move or if there's just some
some kind of quest not progressing
Chris Chris stock up on resources
usually in room requirement getting
plants
oh yeah yeah if you're still like if you
haven't beaten everything yet it's great
because you're gonna need them for like
mallow Suite make sure you start growing
mallow sweet also for Wig and weld
potions you know always make sure you
have a good supply of those absolutely
rotate a schedule every other week
morning streams one night streams the
next yeah that would be tough
honestly like today is really tough
doing the doing one in the morning and
one in the evening
and and you know what Dustin I'll tell
you this I'm a night owl so if I could
have it my way like if I could just if
it was only me in this house I would
probably all be night streams but
I got two kids and so
I had to take them to school sometimes
and when I have to take them to school
it's so early so I can't do like a night
stream and then my wife's schedule is
not like a consistent schedule she's in
the medical field so she works like
three days a week three 12 hour shifts
and so her schedule's all over the place
so I have to schedule all my stuff
around her so it's just easiest when
it's during the day I know no matter
what I'll either have someone here
helping me watch the kids or
they'll be in school even if I'm taking
them they'll be in school for a few
hours where I know I'll have a definite
definite stream time available
oh look what just came today guys if
you're watching on Twitch you saw me
this arrived right toward the end this
is the official game guide
here's the back get all the important
tips and tricks you need to know for
Hogwarts Legacy you can also get them
right here at youtube.com retro Contour
uh welcome to Hogwarts Legacy we know
all this
let's unlock hidden secrets and other
tips for completing the game's various
quests a must-have for any Wizarding
World Fan yeah I'm gonna look through
this yet I didn't have time yet that's
what I was trying to say
but
I haven't bought a game guide and I
couldn't tell you how long I just wanted
to buy this one to see I mean obviously
for a collector's item
given how much we've we've covered this
game but see if there's anything we miss
like if there's anything outside the
trophies that
oh my goodness look at this it has like
oh this is actually super helpful
remember the trophy uh for using ancient
Magic on every enemy in the game
they give you like this little check
checklist
right
e where is it here
nope there there
little checklist
I like that it's nice
yeah I want to look through it and see
if there are any other Secrets because
because
let's go ahead and switch over to our
main main camera view for the evening
here
because I think I've discovered
something you guys
I think I've discovered something that
was either cut
or could potentially be coming later DLC
I don't know maybe
yeah I haven't had a chance to fully
look through this yet
but the art book is awesome it's way the
arbook is a lot more expensive than this
but the art book man some of the
pictures in there just incredible
just incredible Patrick nah you didn't
miss it dude welcome in Ravenclaw Tyrell
with the five months thank you so much
Ravenclaw Tyrell I just realized I don't
think anything's
has anything been popping up
just when we start to get the alerts
squared away on
twitch
now they're not working on YouTube I
haven't seen any have you guys seen
anything have any alerts popped up
I haven't seen any alerts only way I saw
it was in the
in the actual uh chat box that's where I
saw the five months from Ravenclaw
Tyrell
thank you so much dude appreciate you
being here
appreciate you being here my friend but
yeah Patrick we were a little late
getting started
it's quick turnaround time getting
getting dinner hanging out with the kids
for a bit getting them in bed
More Store functionality is what I'm
craving cell potions ingredients
generate a steady income see I love all
that stuff if there was
ether like there comes a point where
it's like diminishing returns like I I'm
so on my main playthrough I'm level 40
I'm so powerful at this point that
any little trait I put on something I
can one shot so many enemies so that's
why I want like a new game plus so bad
something to something to crank up the
difficulty even more
let me play through the game again I
mean learning all the Spells is fine but
let me keep the traits that I already
have let me keep all the gear let me
carry all of that forward
and just make it harder and then give us
a reason like that's why I love they've
built so many great systems into this
game
I really feel like they have a strong
like the trait system I love how all
that stuff works but there we go there's
Hagrid
Amy became a member that one worked Amy
thanks so much for becoming a member
and Hagrid actually responding that time
appreciate it Hagrid
oh hjd97 I have a very credible Source
tell me news about the delay basically
they're having trouble with Xbox One PS4
is where they want it to be a 97 ready
uh oh that'd be interesting
but then what does that mean for the
switch
what would that mean for the switch
right
there's a mod for extreme hard already
no way
you're waiting on yours Ravenclaw Tyrell
oh my gosh I'm so far behind all right
all right hold on we're gonna rapid fire
here with comments got platinum and
working through Ravenclaw
wait you already got the Platinum
and working through Ravenclaw after 100
Slytherin
the Platinum Ryan if you hadn't made it
through on Ravenclaw yet
maybe just got to the point where you
need the Platinum that could be
that could be
these like 10 wig and will potions the
entire game on hard yeah we've been
trying not to use any on our playthrough
today that we started
because the game doesn't really tell you
this at least I haven't seen anywhere
that it tells you this but as long as
you survive a battle
once you get out of the battle your
health will refill
even though sometimes it'll say like use
wiggin well to refill your health
so I've been refusing to use Wicked Will
it wasn't I didn't intend to but then we
started playing today and I was just
like no I'm not doing it I'm not using
wig and weld survive this battle
survive this battle
I wish I would explain the glitches
that's what they're trying to figure out
I'm sure
right now
you Google the checklist yeah it's it's
pretty nice and then you can just like
go through and check them off
would be very useful if I hadn't already
done it but
still nice little fun collectors item to
have and I love the artwork I mean the
artwork in the art book is incredible
it is incredible but even here like this
looks really nice too
get a lot of in-game screen shots
like let me find one for you guys
like look at that that's pretty cool
right there with the spiders
try not to show too many spoilery things
all right let's go more toward the front
here
go toward the front so we don't spoil
anything major
oh that's pretty cool
The Duel right there
Sebastian in the player character
Nintendo power and Game Pro yeah Craig I
was an egm kid
I had egm for a long time
that's a trophy you need skull the
ancient magic one I will say the one
that was holding me back I was missing
two different types of spiders so there
are several well let's consult the guide
shall we
let's consult the guide
[Music]
all right where are they okay so you
have
the thornback scurrier the thornback
shooter the thornback ambusher The
thornback Matriarch venomous scurrier
venomous shooter venomous ambusher
venomous matriarch that's a lot of
different spiders right there
so I just went around looking for
different spiders making sure I used
ancient magic and it was two of those
those were the last two that I was
missing
but then also there's a dark Mongrel and
a regular the regular mongrel
three types of dug bogs three types of
trolls
and then all sorts of human enemies as
well
all sorts of human enemies
[Music]
kind of want to keep the Spells some are
so late game that's true Dustin but see
I I don't know how they would make it
work
with a new game plus I feel like the
easiest way would be like you have to at
least relearn the spells because there
are some spells that you have to get
before you can progress so it's like
your whole left I mean maybe they still
require you to go to lesson
like you still have to complete the
mission even if you already have the
spell
[Music]
I'll let them figure that out though
I'm sure they can do a better job than I
can but New Game Plus please make it
happen
Ravenclaw Terrell you've hit in some
battles
James just used about 25 on the third
trial big battle I didn't make it no
he's playing on did he keep it on hard
Dustin last I checked he was still
playing on hard mode
Amy you're in Hufflepuff after getting
lord of the shore Mount when I take all
the stuff to ollivanders the dude meets
me outside got into a huge fight is
there any advice
huh
when I take all the stuff to
ollivander's dude meets me outside okay
yeah I know you're talking about and you
get into a huge fight and then it's just
like so are you beating that section and
then it's not going forward anymore
or is it just like you're physically
locked in a position and can't move
I will say the Hogwarts Legacy bug site
maybe you can take a uh
take like a quick little video or at
least get a screenshot
and WB game support on Twitter will tell
you where to reach out but I have I
don't think I've heard of that one
specifically
Ryan you jump from 360 to PS5 you're
blown away at how far gaming has come
[Music]
focus on random foes first and go for
the boss yeah yeah for that trophy on
the
the different enemies yeah for sure
for sure you're on easy hey nothing
wrong with that
nothing wrong with that
venomous matriarch was my last Finishing
Touch enemy yeah those spiders
96 done on the field guide
so close
oh you die I see what you're saying and
then you lose all the wig and well
potions oh wait were you once saying
that you were um
oh I see I'm sorry Amy I thought you
were that person asking earlier somebody
was asking about the
I thought you were saying you had a bug
or somebody had a bug that they couldn't
get like a glitch in the game it wasn't
letting them progress
you see where my my mind is on the the
glitches and stuff now I see what you're
asking yeah noobs got it noobs Noob
understands where you're coming from
there
focus on the smaller foes until there's
hardly any of them left and go for the
boss gotcha yes yes yes
he was still on hard Dustin nice Cloud
Roth in the house how's it going dude
welcome in
yeah skull I figured it out now I
figured it out
aka the boss hey Amy may be going no AK
like I did
maybe going for that all good
playthrough you never know
you never know Craig
all right so I mean we've kind of
already talked about the delay news but
let's go ahead and just get into it here
let's get into it so they announced this
on
yesterday just yesterday
here's the message we're overwhelmed
with gratitude for the response to
Hogwarts Legacy from fans around the
globe the team is working hard to
deliver the best possible experience on
all platforms and we need more time to
do this Hogwarts Legacy will launch for
PS4 and Xbox One on May 5th 2023
so we were what we were right at a month
away so I guess you would expect that
was the time when it was probably
supposed to go gold
and they realized it wasn't going to be
there they just needed a little more
time I will say the fact that it's only
a month
that gives me hope that there's not like
a major major issue
now if it was like a two-month thing or
a three month thing or if they just said
We're not gonna make the date and they
didn't even give a date then that would
be a little more worrisome but this like
like putting a firm date on it
a one-month delay the game's already out
on the other system so it's like you
know it's
it runs well for the most part they're
not any too many major major bugs or
anything
um I mean it's opportunity and there's
always going to be some things and like
these trophy things are annoying but
it's not
you know I wouldn't say it's major in
terms it's like it's not like game
breaking right
so hopefully they'll be able to hit the
May 5th date and then everybody on PS4
and Xbox One will be able to enjoy it as
well and then hopefully they'll be able
to focus on on the switch version which
I still can't believe it's coming out on
the switch man I can't believe it
that is still so amazing to me that
they're
right after Star Wars day yeah yeah
exactly
which when you get into may I mean isn't
that breath of the wild two that month
I'm super curious actually to see once
it's all said and done
I can't wait to see what
the breakdown is for where the game
sells the most I mean I feel like PS5 is
going to be Far and Away the most but
there's so much more of a of an install
base on PS4
PS4 might be able to give it a run for
its money
I don't know if they if they will ever
release a breakdown like that if they'll
if we'll ever even be able to see that
[Music]
Lance oh my goodness Webb from the old
smash days dude what is up
hope you're doing well man thank you for
stopping by I wanted to say real nice
watching the Hogwarts videos
glad to see you're still posting
absolutely Lance appreciate it man yeah
I'm glad you enjoyed the videos and
we've we've been streaming more on you
uh on YouTube more on Twitch again as
well
so we've we've done a couple streams
well we've been doing a lot of streams
really we're uh
we're doing this full time now man this
is uh this is officially our
our new career path so
it's been great though it's been great
we did a stream today over on Twitch
played some Hogwarts for about
six and a half hours or so
but yeah dude feel free to stop by
sometime Noob with a super chat retro
pick my house and if I should use the
three No-No curses
have you already done all the other
houses new this is important have you
already done all of the other houses
this is the important thing
[Music]
switch isn't bad Lauren it's just way
underpowered for a game like this I love
a switch I mean we play my boys and I
play the switch all the time but for
like a massive open world game
it'll be tough for it to run
[Music]
to run it especially as smoothly as it
is on on like a PS5
you've seen all the exclusive quests
doesn't really matter okay gotcha I mean
like
I'm gonna say Gryffindor
Gryffindor and no don't use the curses
that makes it harder
Hard Mode no curses
Gryffindor there you go that's what I
say noob
appreciate the Super Chat my friend
and also I think we had a little bit ago
Lance subscribe to the channel Lance
thank you for subscribing appreciate it
my friend
once you get a PS5 you're looking
forward to seeing what games I can play
oh what they look like absolutely dude
absolutely Timothy ninja welcome in dude
how's it going
welcome in welcome in hope you're doing
well
and then here Dustin gives you another
uh possibility go Slytherin only use
imperio use all your gear slots for
improved imperio and let whoever you
choose wreck its allies
that would be kind of fun
hey Ryan how's it going
yeah a lot of people are up are upset
a lot of people are upset it's uh it's
unfortunate
it is what it is right I mean we just
hope that it
hope that when it does come out it makes
it a better game for it
you hope
hard Gryffindor and no to the No-No
curses
sounds good noob
sounds good
yeah me store I think it's harder when
you don't learn the unforgivables for
sure
the dark arts curses in this game my
goodness you guys are so powerful
they're so powerful
without spoilers this Ravenclaw house
come with an exclusive quest uh yeah
it's not really an exclusive Quest it's
all the same Quest but they all do
different things in it Professor Baxter
without giving too much away for people
they all have slightly different paths
that they take to get there and it's
just one it's just one there is some
different dialogue options as well like
based on which house you are
and the beginning is going to be
different based on which house you are
so when you start out as Ravenclaw
you're going to meet certain Ravenclaw
students
before any other students because you
you know you start out at your common
room or when you when you start at your
common room it's not where the game
starts
laughs
Jack Attack do you feel bad for people
in last gen yeah I mean you know they're
the people at Avalanche are disappointed
too
without spoiler I already read that one
from Baxter yeah yeah
doesn't PC typically outsell consoles no
no no no no
not for not for games like this
I mean
I'm trying to think like major it like
depends too
like all the big stuff I mean like call
of Call of Duties the maddens the the
big sellers every year
what else are like the big year like the
Assassin's Creeds
whatever like the main console is at the
like whatever the the market leader
console is at the time
I feel like that's usually where they
sell the most yeah
sounds like an OP summoner build oh with
the Imperial thing yeah
a week before two years of the Kingdom
for last gen
oh man a week that's not a lot of time
hope you'll have some uh a nice
well it is in the summer so if any of
you have school or anything at least
it's in the summer
roll May
oh School are most schools out by then
or that most Schools get out around late
May
not CERN alley
I didn't either Timothy I did not learn
any of the unforgivables nope
I did not
but now second playthrough oh yeah
oh yes yes yes
[Music]
read that console all the consoles
combined barely outsells the PC
for for which game
overall
I mean overall I think PC gaming
probably like if you count everything
[Music]
but like all the big the big third party
games and stuff like
consoles are always the
big sellers
[Music]
why aren't the rugs even straight what
I know skull I can't believe that hmm
hufflepuff's got that
leave it
here's an interesting article Patrick
PC and console sales are equalizing
according to Capcom this is back in 20
20 21.
oh goodness ads stop it stop it
this was August 5th Capcom never used to
be about PC gaming that changed with
monster in her world
by releasing on both I found there was a
ravenous PC market just waiting to dive
into
since then Capcom has been releasing
Resident Evil game okay Resident Evil is
actually a really good example let's see
what it says here so that's like a big
third party game not usually exclusive
to one platform
results have been nothing sort of
spectacular
this aspect continuing PC support come
on tell us the actual breakdown though
okay here we go while demand for PC
versions of games did not exceed that
for console versions in the fiscal year
ended March 2021 we feel that that gap
between the two is shrinking so there
you go yeah traditionally it's like
those big big third party games always
do better on console
you know sometimes if a game has like a
big
like Destiny would be a really
interesting one to study too because
Destiny 1 was not on PC at all
and then Destiny 2 was on PC and
consoles and I think Destiny finally
flipped completely where it is more on
PC but then that's like you know
a massive not not quite an MMO but it
you know it's one of those uh oh what's
the word for it
games as a service I feel like games as
a service definitely are more a little
more prominent on PC
[Music]
I've had both man I've had both I've had
a really powerful PC
oh man are we really going here right
now look what you've done Patrick are we
really about to go here
I've had both I've had really powerful
PC
and I've had the latest systems
and at the end of the day
I'm a console guy I'm a console guy man
I'm a console guy and you want to know
why it's exactly what you just touched
on there Dustin
can also run less stable
because guess what
if Hogwarts Legacy I mean pick any game
right if it doesn't run well on your PC
guess who gets to research why
you do
it could be one of a million things it
could be your GPU it could be your
drivers it could be your RAM could be
your hard drive could be your monitor
it could be so many different things
and because there are so many different
variations it makes it I've learned this
the hard way it makes it way more
difficult to troubleshoot
so you're you're having to figure it out
on your own I had an issue with Apex
Legends man and when I play Apex like I
still prefer to play it on PC I'll tell
you that straight up I do but I had an
issue that persisted for months of where
it would just hard reset my game hard
reset my game straight straight to the
desktop in the middle of the game there
were forums for this on EA
all sorts of other people having the
problem I I upgrade I literally bought a
new RAM for this new motherboard
new CPU which I wanted to upgrade this
stuff anyway but I was like oh this will
be good to see none of it fixed it new
driver updates nothing if something like
that was happening on PS5
because there's enough people like on
that platform they will fix it
they will fix it but with PC it's like
there you go you know figure it out now
when it's all working great
everything's flowing
you got the big best rig out there it's
smooth sailing dude you're good yeah you
get the best experience
but when you don't when something goes
wrong
so like I just don't have time for it I
I just that's the point I hit ma'am
that's the point I hit as I got older
had less and less time for gaming in
general
just like dude I can't like I can't deal
with this I can't deal with this every
time I want to sit down and play a game
I've got to be I've got to know that it
will work fortnite same deal my son and
I play a lot of fortnite together
there was just like issues in my PC just
yeah yeah
so there's my there's my uh there's my
soapbox
now what's going to be really
interesting I would love for the day to
happen where
and Sony's getting there like Xbox is
already there they real they're like
yeah we gotta this console thing
we just got we're gonna keep bringing
out consoles but we're releasing
everything on PC you know
and Playstation they're like okay we'll
release on PC
but not the first day that it comes out
so like God of War 2018. that one they
put on PC but then they're not bringing
Ragnarok in they I don't think they've
even announced Ragnarok yet I'm sure
it'll come eventually
but it is definitely part of their plans
so I would love I would love for the day
where everything's just you know if you
want the highest end top of the line
doesn't really matter you can get it on
PC
and maybe one day like I would I would
look look into it again
but like I just don't have the time just
don't have the time
now that's not to say that the consoles
don't have issues too but when they do
because it's like
you know everybody has the same PS5 now
this started to get a little gray with
the last gen right when they started
introducing the PS4 Pro and the Xbox
series you know the up or the Xbox One X
so it started to be a little bit of that
kind of differentiation and we have it a
little bit with this gen too with Xbox
series s and X but but for the most part
by and large like when there's a problem
on console
it's much easier for them to
troubleshoot and fix because everybody's
on the same
the same playing field you know
[Music]
one issue with the last gen for this
game is that it is a hard drive and not
an SSD even with the SSD
oh it takes a couple seconds for loading
doors I mean it does that on PS5 as well
Jack it does
yeah I wonder if flash gin will have
longer load screens
or the little the little spinning
spinning thing
this is racket tour I can't believe
you're still here listening
sounds like a foreign language
Patrick I've never had that problem
really
maybe you got top of the line PC Maybe
but no I mean at the time I had a pretty
it's not as uh I mean obviously I'm
streaming from a PC now
I have a 2060 super right now but yeah
it was on this one it was on this 2060
super and then Apex they finally updated
it just one day
I woke up I mean this probably persisted
for a year I kid you not a year
I was even working with EVGA the makers
of my
GPU because I was thinking this has got
to be a GPU issue they like EVGA helped
me way more than EA ever did they were
EVGA hit a point where they were going
to send me a new graphics card
because I had ran through all their
troubleshooting steps they couldn't
figure it out
and at the time I just wasn't playing a
lot of other games
and then I was like no I I told them no
thanks because I just didn't think it
was a GPU issue I thought it had to be
with the game
and sure enough it was
and they finally did it
they finally did it
[Music]
Hogwarts has officially outsold Eldon
ring in the UK I saw something about
that today
that it was getting close
82 percent of sales on consoles on PS oh
on consoles on PS5
that doesn't surprise me yeah PS5 is
definitely in the lead right now
remember when you just had to stick a
cartridge
you had to you had to blow in it
sometimes Craig you know
sometimes you had to take out that car
it wouldn't you know wouldn't play but
just clear out that dust be good to go
be good to go
Destiny love ma yeah I know it'd be nice
if there was more of a modding
on Console but for obvious reasons
console makers don't don't love that
oh that's another good point skull the
the player base for certain multiplayer
games yes that's why this whole Call of
Duty thing is such a big deal this whole
Activision deal and my Sony's fighting
it so hard but that's a whole nother can
of worms right
Mods make you worry less oh here's
another annoying thing Patrick
all right Patrick got me going here this
controller right here
some PC games I can't just plug it in
and have these buttons show up
no
sakuro sakuro I played on PC
it ran very well only at 60 though by
the way from software I know not not the
best on PC optimization stuff
but in that game I had to download a mod
to get the PS4 button prompts to appear
see like little Naggy things like that
was it easy to do
was I technically capable of doing it
yes and we did and it was fine
but it's like come on man like I should
be able to plug it in
you read the PS4 and we're good we're
good but no
so you have to deal with like the Xbox
button prompts ah Timothy too big of a
Nintendo fan to ever completely cut out
consoles yeah they they still have I
mean them and Playstation really are
kind of the last two hanging on with
those top tier exclusives but even
PlayStation is bringing them out
on PC
just after uh after a little bit of time
now that'll be the day dude could you
ever imagine if Nintendo started putting
oh
I can never foresee that I would love it
because their Hardware is oh man
some stuff about their Hardware is so
good like the the switch dude right now
there needs to be a switch to
come on man come on it is time we need a
switch too
the technology is there it is there
the Game Boy game boy had that boiled
spinach no the thing did it again it
jumped ahead
that boiled spinach screen
double lays per hour and no backlight
right
speaking of uh Lauren yeah speaking of
uh Hogwarts Lexie on the road I've heard
it runs pretty well on Steam deck
yeah for any steam deck fans out there
I have heard that
PCS like building your own house versus
having already made yeah I built two PCS
I built two PCS actually
the first one I ended up deciding it's
not for me and selling it
and then
I love Mac I really do love Mac I have a
Mac laptop that I use
and for some things like with the new
Mac chips I don't know if you guys have
researched this very much but the new
Mac chips are insane man the the speed
is ridiculous that I have a MacBook Air
which is like the lowest
you know tier of the MacBook systems or
whatever but it's the one with the M2
Chip and it can out
Video Edit in terms of speed my PC with
a 2060 super and a ryzen 5 something in
there
now if it was like a really long video
the PC would catch up and win but like
the short little videos I do five to
twenty minutes the MacBook blows it out
it's crazy dude it's so freaking fast
but Max not as great for streaming it
can be done but there's a lot more
little Hoops you have to jump through so
I still have my PC I still use it for
streaming and still do some games on it
but I'm mostly PS5 and switch these days
they aren't saying PS number PC numbers
yeah unfortunately I wonder if they ever
will if there ever be ever be a way to
see the full breakdown
first console is an Atari 2600a let's go
Professor Baxter
2080 super tried fortnite on both
through series X and PC close to the
same settings my PC
and so then you don't know it's like is
it my GPU is it one tiny little setting
is it the windows uh the Xbox game bar
and running in the background on my PC
what is the cause and you just have to
you have to dig and figure it out
all right it's not just me it's not just
me
store I was on no updates looking oh I
don't know what you're saying there new
store I don't know what you're saying
there
I was looking I had sometimes a bit
loading with even yeah I'm not sure what
you meant there
I did see that Ryan about the 300
increase in PS5 sales
insane all started with pong for you
oh man we're turning this little retro
stream huh hey I'm down with that my
first ever game
guys it may have been the original Mario
Brothers
it may have been Mario on on Nintendo
that's the first system I remember
playing and I have vivid memories of
playing that with my uncle
and my dad played some Mario too as well
um and I do remember I had a friend
whose brother had a 2600.
I was really young I think we played
pong on it one time
oh Tech Mobile oh my gosh you guys
remember techmobile
played a lot of Tecmo Bowl back in the
day
[Music]
people in the replay Squad in the
comments are going to be hating on me
for my uh
everybody's saying this isn't about
Hogwarts Legacy at all what are you
talking about
relax
you can talk about whatever we want I
need to try to include time stamps make
sure I go back and put the stamps Elwyn
the real life nude in the house again
with the five gifted memberships oh and
thank you so much here
hell when you didn't have to do that
again you already donated and gave out
some subs over on Twitch earlier today
but thank you very much and congrats to
looks like Lauren Lauren D Anna Silver
Thread Mrs retro record tour with a
gifted membership Connor Darth starkilla
Joseph guys you all just got a gifted
membership make sure you think Elwyn you
can enjoy our emotes here now on the
channel
spam them as much as you want
and make sure you thank Elwyn for
sending over that gifted membership your
way
you've got to download it on Steam deck
Noob I heard it runs pretty well
obviously you know lower res and
everything but
you also have a PS5 yeah
isn't it man it's it's crazy how as you
get older if you have
you know if you're fortunate enough to
have more than one system dude when I
was a kid my parents were like more than
one system no
no never
I would save up I would get to buy one
system per generation
simpler times
Max have come over yeah dude them the M2
chips ridiculous or the the once they
started making their own chips again
Darren with the Super Chat congrats on
the big career move hey thank you so
much Darren
it has been a blast
it's been absolute blast I've been super
busy I it's so weird I don't even feel
like I
in some ways I don't even feel like I've
left a job because I'm I'm working
harder now
than I was before I feel like
because like obviously I freed up my day
that's the biggest thing like I don't go
to a regular day job anymore
but all this work that I've been doing
on the YouTube channel I'm just doing
more of it now
and we've been like the past couple
weeks has been crazy in our family we've
had a lot of
sickness and we're finally starting to
get healthy again
knock on wood hopefully
but yeah I appreciate the Super Chat and
appreciate the congratulations
but yeah we've got I've got some big
videos planned we release one today if
you guys haven't checked it out yet on
seven things I'd like to see them add to
Hogwarts Legacy
um I gotta update the thumbnail on that
tonight because the thumbnail is not
doing as well so but the people that
have seen the video seems to be getting
a good response but then I have some
other big videos planned for Hogwarts
Legacy for the story and then I'm gonna
start slowly introducing more video
types to the channel which I know at the
beginning they're not going to do as
well but I know there are some things
you guys will definitely be interested
in in terms of other
games coming out you know Zelda for one
Star Wars for one I mean those are big
ones just want to figure out exactly
what I want cover on those games
oh let's see
Dustin with the five gifteds as well hey
thank you so much Justin
let's see Professor Baxter just got one
of those gifteds from Dustin
uh Digi Lena got one of the gifteds
Jason Ryan and Martin all with the
gifted sub right there
make sure you all think Dustin Dustin
appreciate it my friend
thank you very much
thought Elwyn already was here and
gifted and just lurking
no that was the first I've seen Ellen
pop in tonight but you're a wizard Harry
to be fair I mean we did a big stream
earlier today too and Ellen was over
there for part of that
we are on YouTube indeed we're on
YouTube now
Stefan or Stefan prefer YouTube to
Twitch so much
it's funny dude the plan was originally
all the streams were gonna be here
and then they did the
the drops Avalanche decided to do the
twitch drop so we started streaming over
there and we just like we've started
building momentum over there on Twitch
so
I'm still going to keep doing them both
for a while we'll just kind of see how
it goes right now we're just doing more
of the kind of just chatting hangout
streams like this here on YouTube and
then keeping the gameplay for twitch but
I do I promise you guys I was gonna
start bringing more stuff over from
twitch but I just wanted it to be I want
to make sure it's edited in a way that's
I don't want to cut everything out I
don't want like super fast editing I
still want it to be a more kind of
intimate hangout let's play
but I don't want to have all of the
alerts and stuff that pop up a lot
during twitch stream so it took me a
while to tweak that get that set up just
right
so today on our stream over on Twitch I
recorded all the gameplay but I have it
set up to where
I haven't looked at it yet to make sure
but I did a test before and I'm pretty
sure it's set up to where the alerts
will not pop up
on the recording even though people saw
them during the live stream so yeah stay
tuned stay tuned I know some people
strongly prefer one to the other but we
will certainly keep
using both of them for the time being
a lot of browser games yeah yeah yeah
oh man he's One browser game I used to
play all the time job annoyed it was
like a brick breaker game
so many good brick breaker games
still working on your first playthrough
but loving it hey good to hear good to
hear take your time that's what I keep
telling everybody people like they're
like apologizing to me that I'm only
this far through I'm like
don't take your time
don't you don't have to rush like the
rest of us Maniacs no you don't take
your time savor it enjoy it we waited a
long time for this game
Super Mario 64 and Sonic where your
first games oh my gosh Super Mario 64 is
your first game wow that's a pretty big
experience right there
I just bought you and your stepdad A PS5
when they first came out
oh but when they first came out I got us
the Xbox
and I bought my PC nice okay so you got
them all Shamar
we're doing better now Patrick but yeah
that's the way we were feeling for a
while
yeah Dustin make sure you watch it check
it out
don't forget to like share subscribe
all the things
Elwyn is always lurking true true like
you never know Elwyn just gonna pop out
at any moment
pop out at any moment
yeah we've been doing so we've been
doing weeklies me store we've been doing
uh like a Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
during the day on Twitch and then we've
kept our
Tuesday evening stream here on YouTube
[Music]
oh my gosh Owen that is crazy
did James wrap up I know he was still
streaming
well hold on I probably shouldn't just
pull up a bunch of random streams
Let's see we might peek in on James for
a minute okay he's done now he wrapped
up
I wonder if he beat the game any of you
know did he beat the game he was getting
close but I don't know I don't know if
he was gonna get all the way to the end
tonight
feudalism was all your favorite Java
game I don't think I remember that one
feudalism one and two
forgot about browser games oh my gosh
that just triggered another memory for
me there was one that I remember that
website candy stand
they had this great bowling game I love
their bowling and mini golf
new world I've heard about new world I
probably would like that game
is it only PC
not gonna be playing on PC
not gonna be playing nah maybe I might I
might
Elf Bowling there was one called Elf
Bowling
whatever happened to Earthworm Jim I
don't know what happened to Earthworm
Jim
but I do I do remember that one for sure
[Music]
what else did I play there was a buddy
of mine in college that I played he got
me into
I said civilization no it was Rome Total
War
that was pretty fun I had never played a
game like that before I ended up having
a lot of fun with that game
had a lot of fun with that game and then
I played the first Halo I never had an
Xbox but when it came to PC I played the
first Halo
in uh in my college dorm room on my PC
all right we should talk about this last
news story here so that we uh I guess
not really a news story this is more of
a retro wrecking tour speculation
segment so bring it back to Hogwarts
Legacy here ladies and gentlemen
so I told this story today over on
Twitch if you guys were there bear with
me I'm gonna tell it quickly again
so the Monday that the game was coming
out like that night that Tuesday night
so February 6th
let's see Monday
February 6th yep Monday February 6th you
can go here on YouTube the VOD is still
there
we had a very big stream that day very
big live stream we were fortunate enough
to get to play the game early thanks to
WB and so we had an early copy and we
were playing the game live on stream
someone came into our chat
and this is all public I hope this
person isn't getting in trouble for this
but it's all it was all there everybody
saw it
but um I won't say the name but if you
go back and watch the stream you'll be
able to see the name of this person and
of course it's it's a live stream it
could be anybody right we don't know for
sure if there's someone actually working
at Avalanche or not
but we we know for a fact that a lot of
the folks at Avalanche enjoy our streams
they enjoy watching the other Hogwarts
Legacy creators as well so that day you
know it makes sense that we would have a
couple
devs hanging out
and so we were exploring the open world
this is not a big spoiler don't worry
but we were exploring the open world and
the person that was there made a comment
about you should go over to that tent
and try out that
minigame that's a that's a mini game
that I worked on is what they said
and so immediately we were all like
[Music]
the traveling minigame yeah yeah exactly
so immediately we tried to go find it
but when we got up there it was the
little tint that was just the vendors
so you guys if you've played the game or
even if you haven't played the game
you've seen the vendors in the trailers
such you've seen these vendors they have
these little tents that look like this
and so I couldn't find it it was only
the vendor and I was like oh darn and
the person the Avalanche person the the
person claiming they were a Dev
uh they said that it was only during the
day
that you could get to this mini game
[Music]
and so we just that night we could never
find it so we just gave up and I thought
oh you know we'll get we'll get around
to that at some point
and then just I don't know
a week or so ago in our mod chat over on
Discord
[Music]
we started talking about this again or
maybe it was during one of our Lives I
can't even remember
but the mods we started talking about
this
did anybody ever find that mini game
because we were trying to think okay
what could be classified as a mini game
you've got crossed ones you've got
summoner's court maybe the broom races
you would consider mini games as well
hey Ryan thanks for being here have a
good one
and so
nobody ever found it
and so Nico is really plugged in on the
PC scene following the mods and
everything so like once the game's out
on PC I mean people could see the code
and look into everything right
and there's no as far as I know there's
been no mention of any kind of other
mini game
so we've been just like
so anxious like we were actually talking
about maybe this this person was just
trolling us they didn't actually work
for Avalanche at all maybe they were
just trolling which you know okay
whatever
I was like I don't think so that'd be a
really weird thing to troll about right
like
it's not like they were claiming to give
us some amazing piece of information it
was like hey you should just try out
that minigame right just a very
normal thing that someone might say who
worked on the game
but we can never find it
and that's where we thought it was gonna
die right we just thought we'd never
find out anything else so the other
night for the first time I had a chance
to really sit down and look through the
r book haven't read it yet but I was
flipping through just kind of scanning
over all the pictures
and I got to this page
right here right over there this page
and it doesn't really show up well I
don't know how depends on the screen
size that you guys are watching on
probably but
I don't know if you can read this or not
but it says gnome toss
g-n-o-m-e gnome toss
and it just instantly clicked in my mind
the tents look exactly the same as those
shopkeeper tents that instantly clicked
in my mind this is the mini game
this is the minigame that this Avalanche
suppose that Avalanche employee who
worked on the game was talking about
but I've never seen it
I've never seen it it's in this here is
official like this is officially in the
art book
and I know with games you're gonna have
a lot of concept art I mean this is just
how games go there's going to be a lot
of artwork
and some things may make it in some
things may not make it in
but looking through this art book the
vast vast majority I don't want to give
percent under anything because I haven't
looked all the way through the art book
yet but I felt like the vast majority of
stuff in there
was actually in the game
except for this page right here and I
was looking through all the creatures
guess what else we see
remember these guys remember we saw that
concept art very very early
very early
and so clearly I mean maybe they were
just cut
maybe they were just cut from the game
gnomes are common Garden pests gardeners
can remove them by swinging them in
circles until they get dizzy and then
dropping them Over the Garden Wall
you played Harry Potter and the Chamber
secrets back in the day
you know all about denoming the garden
and so what a great nod to the old games
this would have been a fun mini game
developer Dell I'll just call you Dell
so there there are three possibilities
three possibilities
Elwyn didn't Todd tell you in a live
stream there's no traveling minigame he
said he didn't know oh so you asked Todd
from uh I think Todd goes to James's
streams a lot
that's right Ginny yes we'll pull that
up too
good call good call good call let me uh
so yeah
and it's different from the vendor one
I'll show you guys how we know it's
different from the vendor one I think it
was right around 13 minutes wasn't it
Jenny
ah Hogwarts Legacy state of play
yeah I think it was right around like 30
oh yeah I had it pulled up oh I have I
have it right here
we'll get that man see that is not
doesn't the vendor one look different
don't they have different backgrounds
it's not this stuff is it
it looks just like the shopkeeper Place
yeah yeah it looks very very similar to
the shopkeeper
you have these little candles here so
this is 1310.
it is different I was thinking so too
I was thinking so too
so we had that in state of play
and then we had
this right here in the art book for the
game
all right let's go back and play our
music again
oh no where'd our music go
so I see three possibilities
I see three possibilities
option one it was cut
this happens all the time
they're going to have artwork for games
and then they're just going to get cut
they're not going to make it to the
final
in the final game this this happens all
the time right even last minute
sometimes
now the part that's kind of hard to
believe is that someone who worked on
the game
the day that it released they expected
it to be in the game they thought it was
in the game and it and it wasn't
I find that hard to believe however it's
a really big game there's a lot of
people working on it so maybe I don't
know how game development Works maybe it
would be very easy for someone not to
realize that something had got cut
maybe so
maybe so so that I see is option one is
that it was just unfortunately cut and
that's it we won't be seeing it
option two
is that they're saving it or later
I know they said there are no current
plans for DLC maybe they held back
though
they saved a few things like this mini
game
that they could include in some DLC I
feel like that's option two and option
three which I almost I'm almost to the
point of not even considering this one
anymore
it's by far the least likely is that
it's in the game and nobody's found it
yet I just find that hard to believe
because I feel like the PC crowd
especially
with all the tools they have access to
on the PC version I feel like somebody
would have found it in the code of the
game at some point for sure
so it's either it was cut and it's never
coming back in my opinion or
fingers crossed we're gonna see it later
I hope I hope that's what it is now
Benjamin snow
a little Hogwarts because he Creator
because I put out a tweet I was like has
anyone seen this has anyone found this
minigame
and Ben said no but he said he saw one
gnome in the Forbidden Forest
now I don't know maybe he was mistaken
maybe it looked like something else or
maybe it wasn't no maybe I need to go
and more thoroughly anybody in the chat
here has anybody seen one of the Gnomes
[Music]
that's right yeah Ellen we did yeah Owen
the detective we started looking through
the credits of the game
I guess the other option would be that
someone just completely trolled us no no
no that's not because the art book the
art book for sure confirms
even if it was something completely
different than what
our person was talking about in the chat
or it's in game but it's not a mini game
it's a shopkeeper
well then that would mean this is not in
the game this gnome tossing ain't in
there
[Music]
it almost looks like there were others
or maybe maybe there's gonna be like a
troll that pops up back here that's
holding that and you see where you can
hit it on the target
[Music]
I'm gonna say
I'm gonna predict
there's a zero inside information
whatsoever it's just totally a guess I
predict we see this in DLC
I think we do
at some point
it could be a long time now especially
you know with the PS4 version and Xbox
One version getting pushed back switch
version who knows right
who knows if that one still hits July or
not but you would think like that one's
gonna get pushed back I don't know maybe
it's a completely separate team of
people and they're progressing along
nicely on what they need to do I don't
know I don't know how all that works or
if it's the same people who have gotta
finish wrap up the PS4 Xbox One stuff
and then jump to that one
but hopefully we'll see this because I
think this would have been cool I think
this would have been a really cool mini
game
and what a great nod it would have been
back to the old school
games such a great nod
[Music]
Karthik how's it going welcome in
welcome in
[Music]
oh yeah they did end Ryan on the twitch
drops they're done unless if you had
them
let's see this Hogwarts Legacy still
hogwartslegacy.com do they still have
the drop thing yeah they do still have
it up here so if you
go to this site sign in and you know if
you if you actually did it you can't go
back and watch you know you can't go
back and watch an old stream and get it
to work the drops are done there but if
you actually unlock them on Twitch you
should still be able to claim them
here
but yeah it is officially uh wrapped up
in terms of I don't think they're going
to be doing any more at least they
haven't announced anything
they have not announced anything at this
point
use the pulso to be the opposite of
summoner's Court
imagine imagine if it's like a secret
and it's still there somewhere
I agree Amy I think it'd be such a fun
mini game
did Elena a thank you for being here
have a good one
and enjoy
replay Squad
enjoy watching it on the replay Squad
underwater exploration they've already
got the swimming mechanics down could be
a gillowee bubble head jump and not only
do they have the swimming mechanics they
even have diving sections
in the current game but it's like
it's more like kind of a cutscene thing
you know it's like okay you dive and
then you end up somewhere else and
that's it
oh it'd be cool it'd be cool
here's what I'm gonna say for DLC
[Music]
I'm gonna make a video about this
eventually I just don't feel like now's
like the time
but I want to make a video eventually
about what I'd love to see in DLC
because today today's video was
additions that I'd love to see in terms
of just you know updating and improving
the current game
Dustin with the five dollar Super Chat a
thank you Dustin has anybody used the
Transfiguration spell on the vendor tins
to see if it changed just to know him
talks
dude could you imagine no I have not
tried that
I have not tried that
but what an idea
what an idea I love it I love the
creativity
appreciate the Super Chat man
most I almost wish it was something like
that you know
it's just something so secretive that
nobody's discovered but if it is I feel
like they need to start dropping some
hints you know
they need to start dropping some hints
telling I feel like Chandler by this
point I feel like the community
they would have given us some kind of
hint I feel like
[Music]
but how awesome would it be if it's like
this community thing where we have to
solve some sort of massive puzzle
together that'd be nuts
that would be nuts
yeah nothing confirmed Karthik nothing
confirmed
just just speculating
spitballing ideas
that's all
[Music]
as someone stayed in one Hamlet switched
back and forth between day and night
I've done that a lot when looking for a
demigay statues
I don't remember seeing any
but I did have several comments see that
say oh yeah it's it's right behind here
it's right behind there and I'm like no
you're thinking about the the little
pop-up shops this is different this is
gnomed a gnome toss mini game
so I'd love to see it in some DLC
hopefully we do
hopefully we do at some point a from the
Netherlands welcome in thank you for
stopping by
yeah I've seen that too Professor Baxter
I feel like Easter eggs can take years
to discover but
something like a full-blown Mini-Game
could they really hide that from the PC
people I don't know if Nico's still here
Elwyn Patrick I don't know if you all
know as much on the mod scene I know you
uh you two are PC as well but like
wouldn't wouldn't the PC folks have
already found that
like can't they see the the assets for
everything that's in the game
[Music]
September first deal oh my gosh could
you imagine
oh for back to Hogwarts that would be so
epic
waiting on VR to get like Ready Player
One Hogwarts VR
I have seen the dragon skull it's a
great epic epic moment the first time I
saw it I posted a YouTube short of the
very first time I was streaming it too
so we got my live reaction I was just
dumbfounded my jaw just
I was like chat did did you did you all
just see that too and mine happened the
most epic moment I thought it was a
scripted thing because mine happened
right after
the hippogriff Quest
right after the hippogriff quest which
for you guys if you haven't played it
yet minor spoilers you already know
you're gonna fly a hippogriff at some
point but it's a little bit into the
game before you get that that Quest is
so epic
one of one of the coolest moments in the
game
and so then I fly around and I land
and I'm just kind of walking around on
the hippogriff and we hear it
and I just look up in the sky and I'm
right by Hogwarts it it swoops down goes
right into the water like grabbing a
fish or something and then flies off and
I just
I was just Frozen
I broke for a second but chat was
freaking out too we were all freaking
out and so then I was watching uh
expecto go play that same scene the
other day and I was like okay I gotta
see if this is an automatic thing is it
guaranteed to happen right at that point
because I feel like in some there are
some things in this game that are like
for example the peeves moment when
peeves is messing with that student by
the um by the bathroom
that happened to me again today on my
second playthrough at the same exact
spot same exact spot it happened to me
in the early preview that we got when we
had the hands on
out in La same spot it happened on my
first like I think that is set and
scripted so I told James I was like go
over I was like kind of fly around
Hogwarts a little bit
after this this moment and it didn't
happen
it did not happen which to me makes it
better because it was just it was just
completely random moment that had
happened to me right after that
it was so awesome
it was so cool
oh Elwyn answered my question let me see
here I'm scrolling back up
uh depends on if they knew to look for
it Nico says there's a lot of encrypted
data
no way so it could be in there somewhere
um
the plot thickens chat
the plot thickens
not sure if they can see all assets but
I think someone would have found I would
think so too Patrick
it could take years to find every hidden
thing in a game yeah like little Easter
eggs and things I get that like there's
probably a rock somewhere that I don't
know has Harry Potter's initials on it
and a lightning bolt scar in the game
who knows stuff like that I could see
taking years time but a whole mini game
that would be insane
foreign
[Music]
the flu Oh No Way Ryan sorry not feeling
well dude
they looked for a way to reset your
talent points and there is code in a
potion I remember that yes yes but they
were looking specifically for it
I could see that coming in DLC too maybe
a new game plus like resetting talents
and everything like that
oh I've not heard that Ryan let's see if
uh
Nico or Ellen or anybody has an answer
on that also depends on how deep they're
looking okay
find the mirror of era said in the game
that would be interesting
and you get a unique item from it
imagine
[Music]
scripted events right right yeah some of
them are scripted but then that one I
with the dragon it just it doesn't seem
like it was scripted
apparently if you go out of bounds
there's a section of extra map with
nothing there but grass but you can't
get to it huh interesting
he saw the dragon when you were on a
cliff on a landing platform yeah you
could see it on the map too yeah
I don't know if it's do you guys know if
the one you see on the map is that
actually where it is in the game or is
the map one just kind of a random thing
are they both just random
compressor Baxter a with the four months
that's right you got that gifted earlier
right
or is that a new one
I didn't see a new one pop up but I see
your chat coming Kingdom Hearts
uh oh I don't remember the name her
Birth by Sleep
was that it
was that even close I just pulled that
from somewhere in the depths of my
memory it's probably way wrong Kingdom
Hearts BBS had a whole Jungle Book World
section that only PSP players in Japan
could access
by accessing game files that's crazy
the thing with PC is that in any update
they can simply add new files to the
download true true true
not heard about any other Maps or areas
there's Owen said possible the minigame
folders are just taken out at the moment
but could be put back in with simply
simple copy paste okay
but I feel like if it was there now
I don't know maybe not though
you guys just wanted me to do like a 10
hour stream where we searched for this
that's what you guys are wanting
yeah I agree Craig the broom's just so
much more convenient it's great as it
looks to fly on the mounts in this game
and it looks amazing broom's just so
convenient
you can confirm that the current game
files have files for Italian right
that's what Ellen was saying yeah a
talent Point potion
part of the Highlands that seems to have
been cut interesting
car think we can easily go out of bounds
when out on the PS5 with a broom
land and walk around you can't get back
into the gameplay area uh you gotta load
an old save
yeah that's funny skull if you're
floating on the if you're flying on the
thestral they can't see
they got no idea
do it Dragonfire 10 hour stream we're
searching for a mini game that we're not
even sure if it exists
we're not even sure
what's also funny is all the little
quidditch hoop areas you can find of
what appeared to be like early versions
of quidditch and they just aren't uh
obviously you can't play though
Harry Potter is
search for the traveling mini game
retro wrecking tool and the search for
the traveling mini game
I will go to Ben and tell him we played
your minigame we found it
I imagine you have to Revel you have to
cast revelio
15 times
while staring directly north
at a specific Hamlet
at a specific time of day
quaffles just lying around uh you could
see some quaffles in a couple different
rooms in the castle where you see
quaffles
what happens with the quaffle when you
score
oh like if you could actually pick it up
in that yeah
oh too funny man too funny
okay let's see did we talk about all the
news that I wanted to cover there was
one more thing from the Hogwarts Legacy
so we talked the delay
we talked about the
gnome toss mini game which I think we
will see again at some point
I hope we do anyway this was pretty cool
PlayStation tweeted this out today no
surprise Hogwarts Legacy earned the
Player's Choice crown for February let's
see what it was up against
I know I voted for it oh that's great
windows
PlayStation come on now
let's see it probably posted that on
Playstation blog didn't they
Playstation blog
no I don't see it there
look their link is broken
there it is
players choice Hogwarts Legacy voted
February 2023's best new game
wait that's it
that's it
you don't tell us what what it beat out
I guess we could always go back and look
at the wait there's the oh it just says
poll close though
well Hogwarts won it
Hogwarts won it not a huge surprise
good levios an object high enough to
score on the Quidditch pitch
dude okay I'm not making this up I found
this is like one of those random things
that you don't know if it's just a
random bug or if it's actually a secret
if you go through the history of magic
classroom
you can get to that area where there's
like a sphinx
and then there's uh there's some other
big room on the right is it a depulso
area
I think it might be one of the depulso
games something is over there on the
right too because I was doing this when
I was looking for all my field guy Pages
the other day
and I went into that room and there was
this little it looked just like a
crumpled piece of paper on the floor I
mean it was really small looked like it
was all crumpled up and I could lock
onto it
I could lock onto it I could Leviosa it
I could if I just cast basic attack and
it would it would just like fly around
the room I think I recorded my footage
of this too because I was like I don't
know this is probably just a random bug
but if this ever turns out to be
anything serious I'll have this footage
here saved
and so I thought
is there like am I supposed to take this
somewhere am I supposed to put this
somewhere so I thought maybe we're
supposed to burn it maybe because it
looked like I said it looked like a
little piece of paper so I was trying to
like put it in the torch
and I had it hovering over the little uh
the Brazier or whatever
and then I cast maybe the Pulsa or
something and it went flying and I lost
it I couldn't find it again
you found that too Amy what is that
probably nothing probably just a random
error in the code or something
you found it too Dustin what it
disappeared on me I tried throwing it
into trash
hey that's a good idea
see that was me I was like am I supposed
to dispose of this what am I what are we
supposed to do with this
so you guys thought it looked like paper
too
yeah and then I finally
I I don't know if it burned in the
Brazier or if I launched it somewhere
and it went through a wall I don't know
what happened but yeah then it was just
gone
I went back I can't find it again I
tried Ryan I tried going back I couldn't
find it
Merlin's Secret Diary page imagine
I did find that yeah we found that on
stream go ninja we found the that
painting that was pretty cool
pretty cool moment I thought that was
fun
I just just yesterday found the room
with the the werewolves
not actual werewolves guys there's a a
tapestry I don't want to ruin it tells a
story
and there's a little there's a specific
thing you can do with your wands see
areas like that right there
areas like that right there if you guys
have done that you know what I'm talking
about
where you have to do something so
ridiculously specific
that I haven't seen used anywhere else
in the game
I've not seen used anywhere else in the
game this this mechanic right here in
this specific way
that tells me there's more secrets that
we haven't found
you were so confused when it clicked
oh on a new playthrough Ryan oh that's
true I did yeah yeah that's right Jenny
Lord retro Mort can look for it
we could go back and look for the
crumpled piece of paper
the room with the crystal ball yes
Brittany what is up yes we found that
one on stream too
we found that one on stream too and see
the first my first time playing through
guys I play without the mini map for a
lot of the game because I wanted to be
immersed
but that minimap gives you so many I
mean it makes it so much it's way easier
for me to get distracted in some ways
because I see something on the mini map
it's like oh let's go there
I'm gonna go that way
I want to go get this I want to go get
that I want to go get this I want to go
get that so I'm glad I played it the way
I did on the beginning of not having it
you think you know where everything is
Ryan and how to hey when you start
playing you'll know be like oh yeah I
heard about I heard them talk about this
it's here
newspapers at a stall during the first
troll attack talks about a guy breeding
basilisk later you could
yes Ryan yes I found that too
and I just my thought was dude could you
imagine if somebody actually found a
basilisk in this game if it was hidden
somewhere
obviously we know where one's hidden
we can't get in there that we know of we
can't get in there
I saw where game ranks did a video
apparently there's some in the Slytherin
common room you can get it to glitch
where the giant squid will actually fly
through
the common room this looks freaky when
it happens and some people saw it and
thought it was the bassless
they thought it was the Basilisk
actually game ranks in their video
thought I think they said that it's that
it they thought it was the bassless
yeah it doesn't yeah yeah it's actually
people figured out it's like a giant
squid tentacle
like glitching through the Slytherin
common room dude if I had seen that
though in game I would have freaked out
Professor Baxter
you don't want to know the answer
I'll just say there's a fun moment
there's a fun moment Professor Baxter
that's better left
If you experience it for yourself
better left if you experience it for
yourself
but yeah as they said in the chat it's
not something you can just get and use
all the time yeah
all right guys I think that's it man I
think we covered everything
um I've got to make sure on these
streams that because I could keep
talking to you guys all night I really
could I could just keep rolling but
we're going to be live again tomorrow
around I've learned to not put like hard
times on things because
the way our life has been lately it's
been very difficult to stick to a
specific time but usually we go live on
Twitch around 10 a.m Eastern Time
it's gonna be a big one tomorrow man
it's going to be a big one my kids are
both in school my wife's got a lot of
errands to run tomorrow
so we're we're locked in we are locked
in for a big stream Lord retro more
continues his journey down the dark path
for our second playthrough of Hogwarts
Legacy so yeah twitch.tv retro record
tour if you guys aren't following over
there
um try to check us out if you can and if
you can't it will be on YouTube
eventually I'm probably I'm gonna try to
have the first episode up this week this
is going to be a new let's play series
if you guys didn't hear we talked about
this earlier but if you if you hopped in
late it's going to be a new let's play
series we'll post here on the YouTube
channel the journeys of load retro Mort
himself
Lord retro Mort himself
yeah Timothy we're gonna be streaming
Hogwarts Legacy yeah our second
playthrough of the game we're about
like four five four to five hours in
on our second playthrough
yep that's where we're at
that's where we're at so I'd love to see
some of you guys there but thanks for
all the support as always here on the
YouTube as well
um check out our video today that we
posted if you haven't yet and also
there's one more thing I was gonna say
[Music]
what was it
oh well it'll come back to me I'll tweet
it out or something if it was that
important
guys thank you all so much for being
here everybody have a fantastic rest of
your evening or morning depending on
where you're at
and I will talk to you again soon mods
thanks for all the help appreciate it
guys
see some of you in the morning those
that can make it if not
don't feel bad mods don't feel like you
have to be there
you don't I promise
all right everybody have a good one
oh I remember what I was gonna say I
remembered next week next week I'm gonna
write that down right now because I'm
gonna go ahead and get the thumbnail
ready we're gonna do like a full spoiler
cast review
of Hogwarts Legacy
and we're gonna like we're gonna
advertise it is that way so people can
because I haven't even got to talk about
the game with you guys like I know some
of you beating the game some of you
haven't beaten the game some of you have
played a lot of the game so if you if
you don't want to be there I totally get
if you haven't beat it yet that's fine
but there's a lot of you I know who have
who are probably itching to talk about
the game
and so I feel like it's time now
because I'm I don't think I've said
anything about this I've said very
little about the story
other than just passing comments I've
made in streams when people have asked
me
all right that's all I was gonna say
thank you
all right guys later everybody have a
good one talk to you again soon
foreign
[Music]